parlons maintenant du dossier de la
fonderie horne l'arsenic n'est pas
seulement dans l'air à l'extérieur
à rouyn noranda on en a trouvé des
traces dans des maisons fait c'est
remarquable et dans une garderie aussi
radio-canada prélevés et a fait analyser
des échantillons de poussières intérieur
sébastien sauvé professeur en chimie de
l'environnement l'université de montréal
il a accompagné notre collègue thomas
gerber dans cette démarche
bonjour monsieur sauver merci d'être
avec nous dit nous est ce que comme
chercheur vous vous attendiez à ça qu'on
en trouve de la poussière contaminée à
l'arsenic à l'intérieur des maisons
oui j'étais convaincu qu'on verrait des
traces de bercenay clos faut pas oublier
que les méthodes d'analysé sont très
sensibles donc on va assurément capable
de mesurer un peu d'arsenic et comme les
sols sont contaminés comme l'art est
contaminé c'est évident pour moi que ya
là en avoir dans les maisons la question
c'est combien on va en mesurer est-ce
qu'on va dépasser les seuils qui sont
acceptables
en mesurez plus d'en détecter j'étais
convaincu il y en a toujours bon alors
ce que vous avez trouvé ce que vous avez
calculé c'est que c'est presque aussi
contaminés dans certaines de ces maisons
là que dans des milieux industriels
c'est parce que les mêmes mots les mêmes
quantités ou presque les mêmes normes
espérons seulement que c'est comme dans
les milieux industriels mais dans
certains comptes dépassent les normes de
ce qui serait acceptable mais pour un
milieu industriel
dans un milieu industriel ça veut dire
qu'on calcule une exposition pour des
adultes qui vont travailler sur ce set
log sont en moyenne 8 à par jour par
semaine que dans le travail et dans un
une usine où les seuls à l'extérieur
sont contaminées à ce niveau là peut
être inquiétant pour un adulte rita par
jour cinq jours semaine on a la même
concentration dans une maison où il ya
des enfants qui circulent et qui passent
beaucoup plus des bambins et le qui
passent moins d'engrais totalité de
leurs fins l'exposition beaucoup plus
élevés donc on change vraiment
complètement le le paradigme
d'exposition et c'est beaucoup plus et
kid
mais quand on regarde cela dans l'air on
ne sait pas pourquoi on dirait que c'est
peut-être moins pire mais lorsqu'on
comprend c'est que ça se dépose sur nos
objets dans notre know it je sais que
c'est aussi pire dans l'air mais bon là
là ça vient de frapper tout à cause il
ya des enfants qui vivent l'oeil des
personnes qui vivent là est ce que est
ce que c'est c'est acceptable qui vivent
là comment se fait-il qu'il n'y a pas de
mécanisme pour leur dire écoutez il faut
il va falloir sortir de là vous mettez
votre vie votre santé en danger
c'est dans l'air on le voit pas ben ça
c'est que parent ou
d'un imaginaire manga mais contre mesure
les poussières de maisons qu'ils soient
recueillies dans un aspirateur
accumulés ou en surface des objets mais
on se trouve à avoir un un regard sur la
qualité de ce qui est tout type qui
flotte dans l'air qui finit par se
déposer et 6 c'est une façon de mesurer
ce qui est respiré l'air puis convoi est
de voir cette exposition donc oui c'est
clairement c'est inquiétant et il faut
le rappeler l'arsenic c'est cancérigène
donc de sport c'est pour esthétique le
ces points souci esthétique c'est si un
nombre de cancers qui va être augmentée
dans ce quartier doit dans cette région
l'eau parce qu'ils y sont opposés à plus
de cancérigènes que ce qui est
normalement jugé acceptable bon vous et
moi on vit à montréal est-ce que vous
déménagiez vous dans le quartier notre
dame quand on voit les données que vous
avez pu analyser est ce que est ce que
c'est réaliste de penser où on peut
vivre leur faisant le ménage
régulièrement il y aura pas de problème
ou si c'est un peu fou cette idée là
haut je ne
j'ai beaucoup de sympathie pour les gens
qui aillent dans ce quartier là c'est
pas simple non parce que clairement non
je ne voudrais pas déménager là je
serais inquiet si j'avais de la famille
qui habitait dans ce cas
c'est surtout pour des jeunes enfants à
élever des enfants en garderie s'il ya
des trucs qui font pressants donc je
pense qu'il faut faut améliorer les
conditions pour les jeunes cartier lors
il n'ya que plusieurs stratégies qui
peuvent être mises en place lors entre
la réduction des émissions nettoyage des
sols environnants
des règles un peu plus strict un peu
plus rapidement que ceux qui ont annoncé
avoir amélioré donc non potable d'un
produit cancérigène des noms de la
dénommée il faut garder en tête
l'objectif dans 5 1 acquise reste
cinq fois plus élevé que la norme
reconnue au québec
donc c'est pas
ça reste quelque chose où on est on est
là c'est généreux ou assez permissif par
rapport à la norme reconnue et ça c'est
dans 5 1 donc oui c'est un problème pour
les gens qui habitent nos ce qui
inquiète en tout cas effectivement
beaucoup beaucoup de sympathie pour ceux
qui vivent là encore qui n'ont peut-être
pas les moyens de deux ménagés à s'est
tué dix points de rue est beaucoup plus
loin en tout cas on comprend aisément le
l'inquiétude qu'on peut avoir ce matin
alors se souvient merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin c'est très clair
qu'on apprend ce matin merci fait
plaisir merci pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
[Musique]